what uh what is unique about the dating
scene in Dubai let's say that there's
someone listening who's never been or
that they know about Dubai is what
they've seen on a couple of tick tock
videos what's yeah interesting or
different about the dating scene I would
say Dubai is not very representative of
the Middle East and it's got a
completely different culture to like
Muslim values and culture in general the
reason being is it is a playground for
The Rich And Beautiful the entire city
is Beverly Hills so what happens is the
richest man in the world flock to Dubai
it's got amazing perks if you want to
make a lot of money it's just it's where
it is
um and any City where there's Richmond
there are beautiful women it's just
always the case wherever there's
Richmond there's beautiful women so the
playground is completely different it
really separates the men from the boys
both for men and women so what happens
is a woman has to really feel like
everybody's a competition so if she
hasn't worked on anything besides her
looks She's gonna find it's very it's
um it's a difficult place to meet people
because if you think you're the
prettiest girl in the room there'll be
another pretty girl there'll be another
pretty girl there so it's hard for her
to stand out and for the rich guy if he
leads with money he will learn that's
not enough for the women out here
because she knows a hundred millionaires
so what happens is both these people who
brought their kind of their their
trophies to come to Dubai the beautiful
girl and the rich man realize that here
it's a dime a dozen so you have to bring
something else to the table but the
problem is the culture and the
environment is so distracting it's
difficult for Partnerships to connect
and last read on time even though
everybody's craving it most people here
are expats they haven't got their mom
and dad and cousins and family so
they're craving a sense of home but
because it feels like it's so far like
far-fetched like the ego defenses come
in and they just think well I might as
well just play in the mud while I'm here
so it's slightly different to the rest
of the Middle East I would say the more
options mean more happiness things
it's the exact opposite more options
means less happiness they've done so
many studies where they looked at
people's reactions to food in a food
court compared to a home-cooked meal or
even paintings and had lots of choices
or just given one there's always higher
satisfaction when there's no
Alternatives because your brain then
doesn't imagine Alternatives but our
brain has this ability where it can
literally experience what we imagine if
I say to you imagine ketchup on ice
cream you can almost taste that you can
almost taste that if you think about it
enough you can taste it when you have
Alternatives Imagining the alternative
is enough for you to start a desire
there and when you don't have
Alternatives you kind of stay focused
but when you do have Alternatives it
means the satisfaction is reversed so in
a place like Dubai that is swimming with
lots of people with lots of money and
lots of women filled with lots of
silicon there are a lot of distractions
uh endless distractions and even if it's
not the women it's the environment
restaurants are fantastic the bars and
clubs and stuff to do the beaches are
amazing the water will dance for you sit
and have dinner and the water fountains
will go up there is just such a a so
much pleasure everywhere I mean it
really suits me well because I'm quite
extrovert and I I would never say in a
bad way for me it works well but for
anybody who craves more of a calm
peaceful environment I don't know how
conducive a city like this would be
I think that you're right I am
I wonder about
what the Muslim Community thinks of the
recent trend of white Western guys
saying that they're going to convert
that they're now going to follow has
this been a conversation that you've had
with your dad or anybody from your yeah
do you know what it's becoming common I
do think Andrew has a part to play in
that I think Andrew has had a part to
play in it and I think in general it's
um I think what's happened is the left
has become so loud that people are
seeking conservatism again and I think
that because Dubai has become popular
and the idea of the whole gender debate
and women becoming so promiscuous now
people are thinking I need I need a
solution I need a fix okay if you're
looking for not promiscuous women Dubai
is not necessarily the place to go and
if you look at a real representation of
Islam Dubai is also not the place to go
the last place to go I would say if
you're looking for a non-promiscuous
woman there is nowhere
um there's nowhere worse than Dubai
because the promiscuity in Dubai amongst
the men and women but like I always say
it's the only city in the world where
the women are far more promiscuous than
the men far more because what's happened
to the women in I don't want to say too
much but what's happened to the women
that come to rich cities is they come
emotionally detached they come with the
idea that I want to meet a rich man now
that woman is completely different to
the woman that comes to a city and says
I want to fall in love and have kids now
that emotionally detached woman who
comes I want a good life is never
emotionally invested and here's the
mistake a lot of rich men make they seem
to think that if they can support a girl
and give her a good life loyalty is a
given but what they're forgetting is a
woman that craves a good life doesn't
seek emotional intimacy she seeks
financial intimacy now any woman who
doesn't seek emotional intimacy is far
more likely to stray so they're the most
likely to be cheated on is these men
that spoil their women yeah
because loyal women want to be spoiled
by time they don't want to be spoiled by
possessions and a lot of these
successful men don't have time so they
naturally filter out loyal women and get
the ones that are okay with the
financial investment that's again
another difficult sort of hypocrisy or
tough Circle to Square from Men's advice
around the you know looking for
emotional intimacy is simping for women
but paying them in gifts and flying them
all over the world is somehow being high
value the problem the problem with that
is that you are making an incredibly
fragile Foundation upon which to build
that relationship now the cope from that
going one order down is well it doesn't
matter I'm not bothered about building a
relationship because use them and like
you discard them we'll just get on to
the next one and you go okay well
in that case we're not really talking
about the same thing one person is
having a discussion about how to sleep
with lots of women and use their Air
Miles as much as they can and another
person is looking for a relationship and
I think that one of the concerns is much
of the advice that gets put out on the
Internet is given by men that are
optimizing for short-term relationships
but taken by men who actually want to be
optimizing for long-term relationships
yeah you know if you're super clear
super high in sex drive super high in
sociosexuality super low in
agreeableness super low in commitment
very commitment diverse very avoidant
attachment
you are going to construct a world in
which your philosophy meets those
desires for yourself yeah but if that's
the most popular Creed that's put out on
the internet and all of these guys who
don't have that same Baseline of
personality do begin to think well maybe
maybe this is what I should be doing
maybe this is what should fulfill me you
yeah you end up using a philosophy that
was designed for a different machine
than the one that you are
yeah exactly that and here's the thing
with a kind of here's what being a
simpius right he's let me just summarize
what it is it's not about loving and
investing in your partner which is often
the case they seem to think that anybody
who loves or invests or wants a long
lasting or who is loyal is a simp here's
what being a simp is a woman crosses
your boundaries and you still accept and
not only accept you try and get her back
that's what simping is you everybody's
got different boundaries but if you've
seen a woman cross your boundaries many
times you've seen unacceptable behavior
and instead of them withdrawing your
love you then shower her with more love
to get her back that I can understand is
a simp but somebody who vets a woman
correctly and then puts explains their
boundaries and here's what a boundary is
it's very simple the moment you feel
something is not great you communicate
it you don't test your partner to see if
they break it again and so you just say
look I don't like it when you don't call
me after a night out I just want to make
sure you got home okay it's uh oh I
don't like it I think that outfit it's a
little bit too revealing on a night out
can you just be a little bit more
mindful you say your boundaries now if
you don't say your boundaries and you
allow a woman to completely disrespect
him even though you're feeling it you
know in your soul she's disrespecting
her boundaries but you're still begging
her to be with you and she's doing
unacceptable behavior and you're still
begging her then you fall into the
category of a Sim but that can happen
with women men anyone can do that but
strong boundaries create good neighbors
the moment we put our boundaries up
people then know how to behave around us
and we become simp free we become immune
to being a simple what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace